give me a story where you
because because dave's not a smoker
right oh yeah yeah they smoke weed he's
smoking
he just don't smoke weed after before 6
p.m you know what i'm saying he's gotta
be after he smoked like a uh
like he in corporate america well the
first the first episode of season two
was so funny because like
the whole entire weed aspect where you
got the weed in the background
and does that really happen man yeah so
that actually happened give us that
story it was in canada though like
i was uh smoking out there in canada you
know i get the blood everywhere
and it was time to go to the uh to the
airport so
i dumped all the wheat or whatever the
case may be but i still have some crumbs
in my passport so when i go through the
security check-in
they checking me they check my backpack
i'm like oh i'm good man i ain't got no
weed no nothing
and let me uh let behold they pull out
my passport
and it's like crumbs like probably like
dude literally like
dukes when i say crumbs yeah crumbs you
couldn't
like yeah crumbs right so they like oh
he got weed so they hold up the whole
line they pull me to the side they take
me in the cell talking about you
have to stay the tuesday y'all gonna
miss your flight but this is the crazy
trip though
it went from all of that from you got to
see the council on tuesday and then they
backpedaled all the way once they found
out i was a little dicky they like oh
you were him y'all got a concert all
right well that's what we gonna do
i know we made y'all miss our flight but
we're gonna book y'all the hotel and you
know what i'm saying y'all could stay
awake they did that yeah the hotel did
that i mean the airport did that the
airport did that oh
yeah it was crazy man like it went from
the flight is canceled y'all y'all y'all
making the flight yeah we're sorry
literally i was in a cell bro i'm in a
cell
like uh at the airport dj esco like i
was in dubai
oh my god i was in the cell bro i'm in
there like damn
i really gotta talk to the council like
who is the council like
they were supposed to be on the phone
with the judge like trying to set up the
case already but
before all that happened they figured it
out found out little dickie had a
festival in canada
and then like two of the security guards
was fans so they let me go
wow so that actually did happen it
really happened
that's crazy crazy man